it's really strange i was i was talking
to
paul judge and then the harlem capital
founder
pierre henrique you'll come to me in a
second there's
there's andre is that yeah and he said
it's really interesting how
the murder of george floyd has really
made everybody just take stock of this
it is
it's actually very interesting as well
you you have this perception things are
getting better or maybe you don't i
should say i have that perception or i
had this mistaken perception
i think things are trending in the right
way and then you see video after video
after video
and i think it's worth pausing on
the video in virginia of the army
officer who got pulled over for driving
while black and while driving a really
brand new nice car with
plates on it and did you and you must
have seen this video
what are your thoughts when you see um
i've seen bits and pieces of all the
videos but i don't watch most of them
um all the way through it's incredibly
traumatic to watch these things over and
over again
um because it's real and it's really
happening and every time it happens
every single time it happens i just
imagine my brother
uh who's been in that situation multiple
times in his
life multiple times including a time
where he walked out of a grocery store
and multiple officers held guns on him
without explanation
made him get to the ground drop his
groceries and
had him there to the point of he could
have had a heart attack or anything
they'd pick him up after 10 15 minutes
of this and say sorry man
we got the wrong guy and then they let
him go
without anything and so anybody in that
situation
who had a trigger finger or out of my
brother alfred if he had
sneezed yep right he could have been
gone and so it's
i want you to get to your you know do
your point there but i just
have a hard time watching this i know so
many of us do
yeah it is very hard to watch
and i think it's important too for
these conversations to happen hard for
people to have these conversations
sometimes but
if we don't talk about it i don't see
how it moves forward and yeah you know
then
this mistaking a taser for
a gun or a gun for a taser rather is
just
another horrific
tragedy to have to witness again it's
like these things just keep happening
and i don't
know how we get to the other side of
this you have thoughts on it
oh many thoughts um yeah i don't know if
if
if this is the time for me to talk about
it only because again it's
i recently gave the analogy of um
if someone passes away in your family
and you have
a you know either at the funeral home at
your own home
you're in mourning yeah people come by
to visit
and they're asking questions and wanting
you to have the answers for everything
why did they die
how could this happen it's it's it's a
bit difficult to do while you're in
mourning
you know and so i absolutely
i hope everyone agrees i don't think i'd
have a conversation with someone who
didn't agree that this needed to be
different um and i think there are so
many people who have been saying it over
and over and over and over again
these steps people have written
manifestos of steps of things we could
do that
don't include completely defunding the
police because
you still want to be able to pick up
that phone and know that someone's going
to come in and help you
but they but there's so many things in
between
are also obvious right now and there are
answers
the good thing is that there are answers
or people would just listen and if
people with power would just listen
they don't even have to do the hard work
yeah i i love this solution of sending
the right person to the right call
absolutely
people have been testing this and it's
working in so many different instances
so we just have to
really accelerate that you know hey if
there's a domestic situation or if there
is a
i don't know somebody who's suffering a
mental breakdown like
a gun is not what you need in that
situation in all likelihood it might be
but it's probably not
99 of the time you probably can
you know resolve this issue without a
gun and with
talking in words and de-escalation